begin to wrap it up with two items from
the corrective lens this week from the
school chapter
first one
higher education in particular should
recognize that
civilization needs citizens capable of
openness and inquiry these should
therefore be the hallmarks of higher ed
the need for nimble thinking creativity
in both the posing of questions in the
search for their solutions an ability to
return to first principles rather than
rely on mnemonics and received wisdom
these are ever more important as we move
forward in the 21st century
a misunderstanding of how work will look
in the future is driving people to
specialize earlier and more narrowly
higher ed is the natural place to
counteract that trend and push toward
greater breadth nuance integration
students of traditional college age
today cannot accurately predict what
their career will look like by the time
they are 70
50 or even 30.
college is where breadth should be
inculcated
and
um
so again higher education in particular
should recognize that
authority is not to be used as a
bludgeon to shut down the exchange of
ideas
bob trivers evolutionary biologist park
salons and our mentor in college once
advised us to seek positions in which we
taught undergraduates
his reasoning was this
undergrads do not yet know the field and
so are likely to ask questions that you
aren't expecting
dumb questions if you will are ones
imagined to already be settled
when the educator is confronted with
such questions one of three things is
likely to be true
one
sometimes the field is right and the
answer is simple full stop
two sometimes the field is right but the
answer is complex nuanced or subtle
figuring out or remembering how to
explain that complexity or subtlety is
worth the time of any thinker who
deserves the title
and three sometimes the field is wrong
and the answer is not understood but it
takes a naive view of the matter to ask
the question
yeah it's so true you
lose the ability to see the question and
when you're immersed in it and you know
any anyone who's taught at all you know
it doesn't require being sort of you
know a deep a researcher into something
very deep but anyone who's taught
can see themselves moving farther and
farther from the minds of their students
the longer they do it you know the i you
know how was it to be naive now even
like an open wonderful sense not in a
you know an ignorant sense but like what
was that and how can i maintain my
theory of mind and understand what it's
like to be in the heads of these people
in front of me so that i can best
reach them and communicate with them and
they can reach me and communicate with
me
right and the you know the
uh ungrooved mind asks
questions
aplenty that aren't so useful but in
it's it's very much of the question of
the fringe right the fringe is mostly
wrong but within that sea of wrongness
there are
the hints of the next frontier and
the
the ungrooved mind
doesn't know which of their questions
are the good ones necessarily but the
point is you ungrouped i've never heard
this this
well if you become you know
if you become expert in
let's take the this example
our colleagues
do not understand that the waiting time
problem in evolutionary biology is
actually real because it was delivered
in a sea of not very good critiques that
came from intelligent design folks but
the point is it's actually a good
question is there enough time for the
process that you know to have explained
the adaptations that you see and claim
have been
produced by it right and if the answer
is no
it doesn't necessarily imply what the
people who ask the question think it
implies it implies maybe you're looking
for another layer of process
right and so anyway the point is the
grooved minds are so used to saying
here's the process that explains it so
by group so i'm just i'm hung up on this
grooved versus ungroup that sounds like
it could
for me as someone who's done comparative
anatomy i'm thinking like you know the
more the more actual grooves and brains
the higher the cognitive capacity i
don't think that's what you're meaning
to imply i don't know no i mean grooved
as in catalyzed like yes catalyzed right
which the point is if you're very
excellent at something it has a lot to
do with following those grooves because
they lead to useful places rather than
to spinning your wheels so you want it
so okay i know i need to get to this
point that's eight steps down and i'm
not gonna every time spend time making
the first five decisions because i just
already know where i have to go and the
decision tree is right which is what
trivers was telling us was that you need
somebody who is naive in order to help
you see where you've actually made a
cognitive choice that you don't realize
it is a choice because you make it every
time right
um
similarly i would just add that uh
the
there's a parallel experience to the one
i described at first where somebody in
the class is willing to push back
because they just can't stand to hear
you say something that isn't right and
then once they do it and it turns out
that
they get praised for it rather than get
scolded other people want in on the game
and suddenly you've got a whole class
full of people pushing back on you and
each other and it's very vibrant there's
this other thing the flip side is
so it requires
a teacher a professor
who
knows that what they think they know
might not be true
and is willing to say in front of the
class oh
uh yeah that's probably right actually i
had that wrong
or
i don't think so and then come back the
next day the next week whatever it is
and say yep you know you were right i
was wrong right or you can do it
intentionally and so the point is you
can drop something in right you can do
you can do it intentionally but you
would you would not no one would do that
if they weren't comfortable doing what i
just said because because and yeah we've
known too many of these people who are
like well i can't go there because then
they're going to start pushing back over
and what is my domain and i can't take
pushback in my domain yeah we know and
that's that's unfortunately a big part
of the problem and it's not that there
aren't plenty of people who are capable
out there but um if they fear being
revealed as incapable of some part of
what they claim essential to their to
their you know their depth um that that
will basically you know the entire thing
will turn out to have been a potemkin
university or something yes they they
rigged their whole teaching lives around
not being exposed for their own uh
limits and you know yes that's a
terrible teacher you an insecure teacher
is is a hazard to to your ability to
think um
but anyway the thing i wanted to point
out was there's the encouraging the
student to push back because all of the
rewards come from them actually spotting
things that don't yet add up and
figuring out what's in those gaps and
all of that
and then there's the
the detection that a student is being
socially motivated which is bad right
now most teachers use social
motivation to get students to accomplish
stuff even good teachers right um but
the problem is there's a limit to that
to the extent that somebody is very
plugged into what the social authority
is telling them to do it depends on it
being a good authority otherwise it's
just a mechanism to
be manipulated into nonsense and so
the other thing i would do which you saw
me do many times was when i detected
that somebody
was trying to tell me what they thought
i wanted to hear in order to get a pat
on the head
right i would lead them down a logical
chain right to some place that was dead
wrong and then i would basically cut off
the limb behind them so that they would
get the experience of like oh
yeah trying to tell this person what
they want to hear is actually not the
road somewhere it's actually the road to
not knowing where you are and being a
little bit embarrassed and um and but
then you know you've got this great
lesson which is okay if i just led you
six steps down something to something we
all know is false
and you agreed with every step along the
way
where was your error it's crazy to me
how much you enjoy this
well that's the thing is i mean you know
you will agree
i was not hated by my students so it
wasn't like they it wasn't like no it
didn't they didn't work for absolutely
everyone but it was pretty clear right
away those those relatively few people
for whom this wouldn't work and um no
not quite quite the opposite um and
that's not um that
what i just said has nothing to do with
um
anything on there and just that um
some
you know i did i did a lot of things
that you never did and you did a number
of things in the classroom that i never
did and
some of those things that you did i
would watch and go i
i see that that is effective and that no
one else is doing it and i just could
not
bear
to do what he is doing i i couldn't
all right so here's one for you um
a couple of weeks ago i got a
communication from a former student
somebody who had actually given me a lot
of trouble right and was not when when
you when you were in professional
relationship with one another yeah when
you were this is somebody this is
somebody who did not quite get what the
style of teaching was about it was the
rare exceptional person highly
intelligent
but
didn't dig it and said so and anyway i
mean that was like that could that
happen sometimes it was interesting yeah
anyway she contacted me and she said by
the way
first of all she asked if i remembered
who she was of course i remember who she
was you were total we were thorns in
each other's sides right exactly um
but uh i'm not going to use her name
because i didn't check it with her but
um anyway if you're out there you know
who you are you have an unusual name and
she said you know i just wanted to tell
you that i don't think i was ready for
those lessons but um i now get what you
were up to and uh i really appreciate
what you were doing so anyway even in
the cases where it didn't necessarily
work i think there's um
there's the ability to
to see what it's its point is and i mean
this too this this is one of the things
that um
that i don't actually see a way around
this but that modern education
is limited in that the assessment
happens too soon
right um that the assessment both by
faculty of students and by students of
faculty
happens when you're still just in the
thick of it and you know maybe you know
maybe your professor managed to game it
such that your last week was an
incredible amount of fun and you feel
like you learned a lot and so you're
going to write this glowing evaluation
and maybe they weren't thinking about it
and so their evaluations are more
variable even though they actually you
know a year on five years 10 years 20
years on you realize oh that's the
person i learned from why did i write
that sort of mediocre evaluation of them
oh because they didn't you know game it
so that my i was feeling full of
dopamine at the point that i wrote the
thing and the same same thing for
faculty writing
evaluations of students um and
you know i used to say actually
especially after the study abroad
programs you know okay you know final
final thing is not a science thing but
um i just want you know a short essay on
some aspect of this
be it you know five and a half eight
week 11 week whatever it was
um expedition through either panama or
ecuador um that you that you were
surprised by and that you can analyze in
some depth
and i would invite people to
write me another one in a year and two
years in three years so you know i'm not
i won't
i won't be in this relationship with you
then you are under no obligation and um
of course under no obligation to read it
but i'm telling you i will anyone who
sends me these a year on two years on
three years on reflection about this
thing that we just did that i created on
your behalf and on my behalf and on our
behalf and that i allowed a lot of
serendipity to happen so that i couldn't
predict everything that would happen or
all the lessons learned i would love to
see those
and there are a couple there are a
couple of people um who do send me um
who send me those years many years later
and
it's amazing because you know the idea
of assessment when you're still in the
thick of the thing that you're supposed
to have learned
imagines again that learning that you
know that
that the short time horizon is where
it's at and it's not
well there are three things
there one it reflects what you said up
top about
i'm not your employee you're not mine
yeah there are superficial resemblances
between this relationship and that but
that's not what this is and to the
extent that anybody
would take seriously your assignment
that gets turned in at their discretion
years after
any relationship any formal relationship
at all exists the point is well actually
you as the professor were trying to
create an experience that was meaningful
enough that years later it would still
be on your mind and that's of course
what you should be doing right
and the fact that uh you know
you and i know if you've been in the
field with students right you've been
suffering with them you've been you know
shocked
alongside them right you've seen amazing
things together
right you know it's obviously
the experience is
one off for each of us but there's so
much that gets that's in that
relationship that doesn't get quantified
that doesn't get evaluated and of course
it builds this connection that years
later they want to tell you you know
what that actually meant to me you know
what it meant to me i didn't get for
three years right right and then finally
it dawned on me and of course the idea
that you're important enough to them
that they would think to tell you
right is a demonstration that this this
actually did live up to what
the experience was supposed to be it
wasn't encapsulated in any way and
that's what you know the the all too
common and pat phrase now you know
lifelong learners right but that's
there's honor in that that's what we all
should seek to be and uh an educational
system that is functional
should inculcate that desire in people
who are currently called students and
may later be called teachers or
carpenters or scientists or whatever it
is they're they're called um and they
should want to both continue to learn
and
yes it's deeply human to want to share
with those who helped create the
experiences in which they learned the
thing uh what it is they learned
yeah and uh yeah unfortunately the
attempt to systematize education has
driven all of this stuff that's hard to
explain and even harder to defend you
know it's driven and out of the system
for most people so they just don't
ever encounter it i guess it's terribly
sad
[Music]